Andrew Wilson, king of olive jar
openers, debater of only fans models,
measurer of Muhammad's manhood, and
occasional orthobro is leading his
unsuspecting followers straight into the
wideopen arms of a nuclear antichrist.
You heard me correctly. If Andrew Wilson
is successful, we will witness the rise
of an antichrist armed with nuclear
weapons. People keep making fun of
Andrew because he couldn't open a jar of
olives. The man's about to open a jar of
nuclear Antichrist and pour it all over
us. Millions of lives will be lost.
Maybe yours, maybe mine, maybe Mike
Wingers. All thanks to Andrew Wilson.
And I'm about to prove it using Andrew's
airtight logic. I strongly suggest you
pay close attention lest you join him in
aiding and abetting a nuclear
antichrist. In his debate with the
apostate prophet on whether Christians
should support Zionism, Andrew laid out
what he considered his most important
argument. My last argument is the most
important. It combines two arguments
together for the sake of time. This
argument focuses on the biggest not for
Christians and requires a preface. The
first preface is that Israel refuses to
disclose if it has nuclear weapons and
will neither confirm nor deny if they do
nor allow any inspection of them if they
do. Our own CIA has confirmed they do,
but they don't disclose it. Israel
neither confirms nor denies having
nuclear weapons, but it's widely
believed that Israel has somewhere
between a hundred and several hundred
nuclear warheads. So if someone, an
antichrist for instance, were to seize
control of Israel, he or she or Z would
most likely end up with a nuclear
arsenal. Second, the Israeli government
works handinhand with the Temple
Institute and American Evangelicals.
Also, there is an organization called
Kufy or Christians Unified for Israel.
Kufy has 10 million members and Israel
doesn't even have 10 million citizens.
Goofy spreads the false heresy of
dispensationalism and host chararismatic
doctrine heresy as well. By Ridan's own
faith, he knows these are heresies.
Goofy's on over 300 college campuses and
growing. Their stated goal is to educate
millions of Americans on these heresies.
according to their own website, quote,
"Through our 16 social media accounts,
websites, blogs, daily briefs to bring
in groups of pastors and next generation
influencers and students to Israel every
year, guys like Charlie Kirk and dare I
say, Rid Van and David Wood and others."
To quote, "Those would be the types of
influencers who would be their target."
Not saying that that Kofi paid for any
of that. I'm just saying that would be
the target. After hearing Andrew's
terrifying warning about the sinister
organization that's targeting AP and me,
I went to Kufi's website. Under mission,
we have as the largest pro-Israel
organization in the United States with
over 10 million members, Christians
United for Israel, Kufi, is the foremost
Christian organization educating and
empowering millions of Americans to
speak and act with one voice in defense
of Israel and the Jewish people. Kufi's
diversity across political, ethnic,
generational, and denominational lines
maximizes our impact in communities, in
the media, on campus, and in our
nation's capital. Kufi is committed to
confronting indifference and combating
anti-semitism in all its forms, wherever
it may be found. Christians from various
denominations uniting to combat
anti-semitism. What could be more wicked
and heretical? said the online alliance
of gropers, orthobros, jihadis, and
Candace Owens. Now, what do these people
want, you ask? Well, they This is going
to blow your mind, but this is what they
want. They want to assist with the
fulfillment of biblical prophecy to
bring about a new false messiah and
usher in an Armageddon. Not
kidding. They're trying to usher in an
Armageddon.
I'm getting ready to take a closer look
at Kufi's policy. At Christians United
for Israel, we are committed to Israel's
strength, security, and sovereignty. To
this end, we stand with the decisions of
the democratically elected government of
Israel and work to support the USIsrael
relationship and safeguard the Jewish
state's right to defend
itself. To be fair, I don't agree with
this policy. They say, "We stand with
the decisions of the democratically
elected government of
Israel." All their
decisions. I wouldn't make a blanket
statement about agreeing with the
decisions of any government made up of
mere human beings, but let's be serious
here. Does Kofi sound like a group
that's obsessed with ushering in an
Armageddon? Andrew made them sound like
a doomsday cult.
Now, the Temple Institute's goal in
Israel, using both private and Israeli
state money, is to rebuild the third
temple and name a Messiah, which
Christians know is a false messiah. The
Temple Institute is an organization that
wants to build the third temple, but
they aren't trying to name a Messiah.
The only source I've seen for that is
Andrew Wilson's Trust Me Ortha Bro. They
don't even seem like an exceptionally
large group based on their videos. And
there are lots of other religious Jews
who reject their views. So why am I
supposed to think that this is going to
lead to an
antichrist right now? This second major
personalities on the right such as
Charlie Kirk, most of the Daily Wire,
even perhaps David Wood and Ridban
themselves who I like know for sure that
any Messiah named by Israel will be
Antichrist. They know it. Suppose AP and
I and others don't believe that Israel
is on the verge of naming some Messiah
and so we don't even think about it. But
maybe we should think about it. After
all, we have an elegant conspiracy
theory from Andrew Wilson. Here's the
recap. So, to recap, the supposed
secular Zionist government is giving
money to the religious Zionists in
Israel and get American support to do
this with both American government money
and direct aid with mega preachers like
John Hegy leading the charge in America
with Kufi to back this endeavor to usher
in Antichrist.
So, Ridban, I will see any argument you
make for why Christians ought to support
uh Zionism and I will raise you one
antichrist as not not. So, the basic
reasoning is if you support Israel's
right to exist and defend itself, you're
supporting the rise of an antichrist. As
a Christian, you shouldn't support the
rise of an antichrist. Therefore, you
shouldn't support Israel's right to
exist and defend itself. This is very
strange reasoning, especially if you
don't lump everything together like
Andrew keeps doing. Let me break this
down for
you. Jews are currently not allowed to
pray on the Temple Mount. Around half of
Israelis believe that Jews should be
allowed to pray on the Temple Mount. And
there are both religious and secular
reasons for this view. There are
religious Jews who want to pray on the
Temple Mount. There are non-religious
Jews who don't want to pray on the
Temple Mount themselves, but they don't
like the fact that religious Jews aren't
allowed to pray there. Everyone
combined, around 50% think Jews should
be allowed to pray on the Temple Mount.
Around 30% of Israelis want the third
temple to be built. Here again, there
are both religious and secular reasons.
There are religious Jews who want a
temple. There are secular Jews who want
Jews to have authority over the temple
mount. What percentage of Israelis want
to build the third temple and name a
Messiah? I have no clue, but it doesn't
seem to be a huge percentage. In other
words, the percentages of supporters
drop significantly with each additional
step. What percentage of Israelis
support Israel's right to exist and
defend itself? Vast majority. What
percentage of Israelis support the right
of Jews to pray on the Temple Mount?
About half. What percentage of Israelis
support the construction of the third
temple? Around
30%. What percentage of Israelis support
the naming of a Messiah? probably a much
smaller percentage and even those who
agree with the general idea wouldn't
agree among themselves because there are
lots of different groups with different
beliefs. Andrew, however, lumps some of
these things together. He lumps together
the goal of constructing the third
temple with the goal of naming a
Messiah. I'd love to see the source on
that. Sadly, Andrew isn't big on
sources. What references should I give
you for logical arguments except me?
Trust me, Ortho, bro. So, until we have
a good reason to think that by
supporting Israel's right to exist and
defend itself, we're actually supporting
the naming of a false messiah, Andrew's
argument just doesn't work. But maybe we
missed something. Here's the formal
version of the argument. So, the formal
argument goes like this. Premise one,
Christians should not support false
messiah or antichrist ever. Premise two,
Zionists are attempting to name a false
messiah. Premise three, secular and
religious Zionists are working together
to bring about biblical prophecy and
name a false messiah. Conclusion:
Christians shouldn't support Zionism,
especially not a Zionist nation with an
antichrist at its head and nukes, which
it won't acknowledge.
False messiah, head of a state with
nukes. Genius Riden. I agree with the
first premise. Christians shouldn't
support an
antichrist. The rest of Andrew's
presentation, however, didn't give me
any real reason to think that by
supporting Israel's right to exist and
defend itself, I'm supporting an
antichrist. I support the right of the
United States to exist and defend itself
even though there are all kinds of
groups in the United States with all
kinds of agendas that I don't support. I
support the right of Canada to exist and
defend itself even though for all I know
Canada could vote in an
antichrist. Andrew's reasoning here is
seriously sloppy and dare I say
unbiblical.
Think about something like the parable
of the good Samaritan. The Samaritans
and the Jews were enemies. Both groups
believed that the Messiah was coming and
both groups believed that the Messiah
was going to be on their side against
their
enemies. But in Jesus' parable, a
Samaritan was walking on the road to
Jericho and he found a Jew bleeding and
dying after being robbed. According to
Andrew, the Samaritan should have
thought to himself, h if I help this
guy, he might support a future false
messiah. If I help this guy, he might
even turn out to be a false messiah. I
don't want to help a false messiah.
Therefore, I have a moral obligation not
to help him.
Jesus, of course, didn't use people's
theories about false messiahs to argue
that they shouldn't help someone in
need. Instead, he told his followers to
go and do
likewise, help people in spite of
religious disagreements. Now, to be
clear, if I thought that by supporting
Israel's right to exist and defend
itself, there was a high probability
that I would be supporting the rise of a
nuclear antichrist, I would agree with
Andrew. The problem is that when I sit
back and think, what could potentially
make Israel desperate enough to name a
false messiah and start a nuclear war?
The scenario turns out to be massively
different from the scenario Andrew
described. What could cause Israel to go
nuclear in the 21st
century? Probably the same thing that
would cause the United States or the
United Kingdom or China to go
nuclear. Israel would have to be
surrounded by their enemies, abandoned
by their allies, on the verge of
destruction with no other option.
If things are going well and they're
safe, I just can't see it
happening, there wouldn't be nearly
enough support from the population or
their leaders. But if they're desperate
enough and they have to decide between
being annihilated or massive
escalation, then I could see it
happening. But think about this.
Andrew is telling two billion Christians
that they have a moral obligation not to
support Israel's right to exist, not to
support Israel's right to defend
itself. I assume he'd support boycots to
crush Israel's economy. That way, the
new Antichrist wouldn't have much
funding. And I'm guessing Andrew would
support measures to Israel's
military since we don't want the new
Antichrist to have a strong military.
But wouldn't losing the support of
Christians and losing the support of
Western nations and losing the ability
to stand against the endless attacks of
jihadis be far more likely to bring
about what Andrew
fears? In short, a strong, safe Israel
with plenty of friends and allies, no
nuclear antichrist. A weak, vulnerable
Israel abandoned by everyone, surrounded
by enemies, and trying desperately to
avoid a fate far worse than what
happened on October
7th, significantly more likely to
massively escalate.
This means, of course, that Andrew
Wilson and his followers are, whether
intentionally or unintentionally, part
of a global campaign to support the rise
of a nuclear antichrist and to usher in
an
Armageddon. Should Christians support
Andrew's diabolical mission? Of course
not. What should Christians do? We
should support keeping Israel strong and
safe. Now, I'm a simple man, so I'm
inclined to support people who are
surrounded by jihadis just because I
don't want them to be destroyed by
jihadis. But since we've got some
orthobros watching, I have to explain
everything in terms of avoiding a
nuclear antichrist. So, here goes. Do
you want to avoid a nuclear antichrist
and the Armageddon Andrew Wilson is
obsessed with causing? If so, you should
recognize that entire nations are
striving to paralyze Israel's economy.
And I'm not just talking about hurting
big companies. I'm talking about hurting
small family businesses. There are
Christian and Jewish small businesses in
Israel, which take a hit after every
terror attack because tourism plummets.
Tens of thousands of small businesses
closed in 2024 because there was almost
no tourism. A company called Artza threw
a monkey wrench in Andrew Wilson's plot
to destroy Israel's economy by gathering
products from local artisans in
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem and
other locations and shipping them around
the world in arts of boxes. Just think,
you can help stop a nuclear antichrist
and get handpicked treasures from the
places where Jesus walked. All by
signing up with Artza. You'll get
candles, Israeli spice mixes, olivewood
carvings, mosaic art, decorations,
cosmetics, candy, games, all kinds of
things delivered right to your door.
Just don't ask Andrew to help you open
any jars. There's a new box every
season. Four new boxes every year. I put
a link to the Artsa website in the
description box. Use the promo code
dizzle to get a discount and to let them
know who sent you. And remember, if you
don't sign up for an arts box, you're
ushering in Andrew's Armageddon and
supporting a nuclear
antichrist. Genius. Andrew
[Music]